removing abandoned commercial fishing
gear
gathering data by surfing and catching
invasive species
these are some of the ways people are
saving our decimated oceans
meet the deep blue defenders taking care
of our marine biodiversity
our journey takes us to costa rica more
specifically tortuguero to witness the
yearly hatching of baby sea turtles and
meet the people protecting them we
arrive by way of la pavona a small port
town with one restaurant and a pay
toilet
our boat operator jairo guzman takes us
down the lucky river
it is a one hour journey to the island
itself
the view is beautiful
[Music]
nearly all species of sea turtles are
endangered and this island is a
prominent nesting ground for both green
and leatherback sea turtles it was here
in 1959 the very first sea turtle
conservancy was opened by dr archie carr
to specifically study green sea turtles
as they were nearly extinct
this was their original base
this is their new base
along with us from the conservancy is
jaime head field director
david station manager
sylvia outreach coordinator
and their 10 research assistants
they all work here to educate the public
and gather data on the current sea
turtle populations
on day one we meet in the middle of the
night to count nesting turtles and the
eggs they lay now let's go to the beach
around dawn we spot a turtle she's
laying her eggs
[Music]
she is one of 36 000 turtles nesting
this season on the beach each turtle
will lay around 110 eggs
in two months they will hatch
we get some sleep and that afternoon we
ask jaime about the hatchings
he says
the best time to catch it is right at
dawn around 5 30 in the morning
that means we have some down time on the
island
david invites us to his makeshift office
we discuss the vision of the conservancy
basically we are working here on the
legacy of dr archie carr he had this
idea of changing the mentality of the
people from harvesting the turtles for
their own consumption and for making
money out of the meat and the eggs into
an ecotourism-based
culture it's a very complex thing to
protect the turtles
on day two the alarm goes off
the team gathers and we head to the
beach
we are gonna need a bigger boat
[Music]
for a while
we see nothing
and then
baby green sea turtles begin making
their way to the ocean
[Music]
only eighty percent will make it out of
the nest and of those 1 in 1 000 make it
to adulthood
this means that out of nearly 4 million
hatchlings this season only around 3 000
will become adults
and the odds are stacked against them
there's more downtime
on our final day day three we go to the
beach to excavate a hatched nest
the research assistants do this job
it is messy
they're counting how many eggs have
hatched in this nest nine did not make
it
they'll add this information to their
decades of existing research
that afternoon jairo's father gusman
senior picks us up
as we leave tortuguero i can't help but
think of something sylvia said back at
the base
la isla
[Music]
sea turtles are not going to stop being
endangered this year
and they probably won't stop being
endangered next year either
but it's good to know that there are
people out there working hard to make
change happen
[Music]
roughly every year 360 000 tons of
fishing gear is lost in the water
even though they're abandoned they are
still catching animals and i was always
appalled that nobody was doing anything
about them
my name is kurt lever i'm the president
and founder of ocean defenders alliance
we get volunteer divers to remove
abandoned commercial fishing gear so all
the nets traps and lines that are out
there they're still killing animals
that's what we focus on removing
typically in a year we will have 10 to
12 whale entanglements from this fishing
gear over the last four years
that number has climbed from 12 roughly
to 72 so it's getting worse
our main focus are abandoned lobster
traps
these lobster traps and crab traps have
lines attached to them and the line has
a surface marker buoy that goes to the
surface and a boat comes along and cuts
that
or it gets moved around in the storms
and the fishermen can't find it they
don't leave them behind just for no good
reason
be prepared to move fast if i need to
push this off
our expeditions are pretty chaotic i'd
have to say we start out early in the
morning with usually six divers
it's really difficult to locate these
traps because obviously you can't see
through the water it's like a hunt and
peck kind of
thing and it's not cost effective but
when you're talking about life does it
matter if it's cost effective or not
not in my eyes i get them out to a site
we drop anchor
say they come across a trap they attach
a lift bag to it the lift bag then goes
to the surface
[Music]
with the trap attached to it and then we
put it on the hoist
clear
the oceans have been really decimated
over our lifetime
i'm a fighter i will go down fighting
and most of my volunteers feel the same
way
i don't know if i'm making a big
difference in the overall scope of
worldwide problems you can only tackle
so much in your life and i'm doing what
i can personally
when you get down there and see the
impact that you're making locally
that's what keeps us going
[Music]
you get mixed emotions when you're out
there hunting the lionfish
a feeling of accomplishment because
you're actually making a difference a
feeling of competitiveness because the
fact that in my case i'm trying to be
florida's lionfish king
lionfish are a
non-native species to the atlantic the
gulf and the caribbean
because they reproduce at such a high
rate and have zero predators they are
currently taking over
the waters here lionfish eat basically
everything that we eat which includes
crabs lobsters grouper flounder anything
you name it their game
[Music]
the scary part is is that we don't know
how many of them are out there and it's
probably a lot bigger than we ever will
know because of the fact that we always
dive the public spots or the private
fishermen spots but i mean the ocean is
huge
[Music]
the lionfish challenge is a contest set
up for those of us that are making a
difference to go out and kill as many
lionfish as we can over the next four
months
not every person is a big fan of spear
fishing but the problem that we have
with the lionfish these things need to
be eliminated
every one of them and whether you're a
big fan of it or not this is just not
about spear fishing it's about taking
care of our ecosystem and making sure
that everything stays balanced
[Music]
being crowned the lionfish king would
will be a huge accomplishment but
it's not just about that
the next weekend i'll probably go out
and do the same thing again even though
the competition is over
[Music]
to be able to be doing science while
you're out there on a surfboard surfing
down the face of a wave
it's just such a fleeting moment it's
incredible to actually be able to do it
[Music]
smart fin is a surfboard fan
you clip it on the bottom of your board
you go out for your surf session
it has technology that measures ocean ph
salinity ocean temperature and very
detailed wave characteristics so there
will be an enormous amount of data
the reason these parameters are
important is because they're shifting
directly as a result of climate change
we had detailed information about the
deep ocean but very limited accurate
information about the near shore
satellites can't be really accurate with
data in that narrow zone and the other
way is ocean buoys and they're just not
deployed at the coast
bingo smartfin can fill that gap
[Music]
collecting oceanic data is a very time
consuming expensive process
this is like you just need to know how
to surf
the data moves from your fin
to your phone via bluetooth and then
from your phone it goes up to our
servers where everything's processed
i had to develop sensors that don't
affect the surfboard nobody's going to
surf a fin that is not a standard foil
aside from that led right there that's
blinking that tells you that there's
like some sort of technology in there
you wouldn't know the difference
so we've got a test tank set up now
and we're just trying to
look at the precision and accuracy of
the instrument itself
things are looking pretty promising
as a scientist it's pretty exciting to
be able to get data over these different
time and space scales
i mean the fact that you can go out and
surf and contribute to understanding
what's actually happening out there is
incredible
i'm not a surfer i know nothing about
surfing i know i look like a surfer but
um
i'm not
surfers are very influential and care
deeply about the environment and want to
be talking about it so smartphone is
just a tool to do that in a more
concrete way
[Music]
hey everybody my name is drew beebe and
i'm here in my terrible home studio that
i've made during quarantine and i wanted
to tell you about our new podcast called
great big story it's got more surprising
and delightful stories just like this
one so head over to apple podcast to
spotify wherever you get your favorite
podcasts and download great big story